seven seconds and the clock is ticking
down for farouza he has to find a good
place to hide the king and he steps
forward
uh
that looks a slightly
like it could get into serious trouble
it looks hairy
it looks like it's almost trapping
itself it's like a help mate but there's
no way to trap it yet no way to uh no
way to kind of no deliver the killing
blow to that king any check you give the
bishop either the white king will run
away or a check along the diagonal might
be blocked by a white pawn
but okay as long as i don't get
distracted by that kind of checkmating
ideas against the white king i think the
plan is pretty simple just push a pawn
yep and automatic does that with a few
seconds left for russia we should
mention he made his last move with one
second left on his clock he made that
decision to put his king on the side
intense okay rook keeping an eye on on
that black pawn
the evaluation bar shot up now black
must have a win
where is it black that must involve some
kind of threat against the white king
yeah i thought that the bishop could
come in and guard the pawn
i think he's going for checkmate ivanka
i think he wants to go for that white
king okay
well what happens if the white pawn
steps forward then the black king will
also step forward okay so now our tamiya
says fine let's go for broke let's just
start pushing my pawns and here comes a
mating net so there's a threat of
checkmate in two moves if white
continues pushing that pawn almost to
make a new queen the black bishop will
slide back one square with a check
and then the king would move martin chop
and the rook would trap that king but
this is still an operation david the
king is caught in a cage there's no way
to save the white king and feruzio
resigns runs off in a hurry wow i want
to come back by vladislav our time you
have to tie the match with one game to
go in the rapid if that one is a draw
these two will head into uh tie breaks
if one of them wins it that person will
be in the big final of the aim jazz u.s
rapid we're gonna jump into game four
between magnus carlsen and levon aronian
it's a must-win situation for levon
aronian to take it to tie breaks any
other results